and the College Board will start
assigning an adversity score to all
students taking the SAT to capture their
social and economic background it's
meant to help admissions officers
account for any disadvantage stemming
from those factors the score is
calculated using 15 factors including
the crime rate and poverty love poverty
levels from the students neighborhood
the formula does not consider race
colleges will see the scores when
reviewing applications 150 institutions
are expected to use this test this fall
David Coleman is the CEO of the college
board he is here to discuss the
organization's new approach and its
response to the massive college
admissions scandal good morning good
morning good to see you um so you've
probably seen this one critic in the New
York Times said if the SAT needed a
sophisticated conventional or contextual
framework to make it valid then that's a
sign that it's not a good test so why
did the College Board decide to create
the university to us what the SAT is is
a valid measure of your achievement what
have you learned in reading in math how
ready are you for college but what it
doesn't measure alone
is it doesn't measure what you've
overcome the situation that you achieve
that in what that we can do with this
context data is see how resourceful you
are have you done more with less so to
be clear it's not really a personalized
adversity score it's the general context
of your school and neighborhood and what
it's really aiming to do is highlight
those resourceful students let me give
you an example a college that we
partnered with just let in a young woman
from Mississippi she happens to be a
rural white young woman in a very small
school and her SAT score was pretty much
average with the other applicants but
what they found when they looked at it
in context is it was 400 points higher
than any other kid scored at her school
the neighborhood Eve the world she lived
in was rife with poverty it's a small
school without a lot of advanced
opportunities but she made the most of
it
so we're saying the SAT shows you
achievement but what it can't show alone
is your resourcefulness doing more with
less yeah so and that's that's the point
you're trying to make I hear is that
it's really about putting it all in
context it's calling it the adversity
score some people would say it should be
called the privilege score yeah I think
calling it a score is kind of a mistake
if you don't mind it's really a
background so every kid in the same
school or same neighborhood gets the
same background information we use no
personal data
don't colleges have access to that
information all they have some data in
you're right this is really making what
colleges already do a lot better
we've long agreed in American education
that we should recognize students who
have defied the odds to accomplish
enormous things and so they try to use
school profiles they try to use a jumble
of evidence and all we're doing is
providing that in a more fair way so
schools that might not have as much
resources to make their profile and
might not be as well-known to admissions
officers can be seen in the same light
so they can witness the neighborhood in
which students grow up and really all
this is about
is there is so much more talent than we
can see than by using scores alone David
you say it's a valid measure of
achievement a lot of people would think
and these are people who would probably
not have adversity that could count
against them they think it's a valid
measure of your ability to cram for an
idiosyncratic test and so they get their
kids into the you know various study
programs people are thumbing through
books going crazy what about that
criticism of the essay it's a pretty
old-fashioned picture of the old SAT in
2014 we revised the test and partnered
with Khan Academy to make the best of
test preparation free for the world now
30 seconds after taking an exam like the
PSAT you get a personalized study plan
for free and you practice just what you
need to get better at in reading and
math this is not a mysterious test to
test a few core math skills you use over
and over again and your ability to read
with confidence so eight million
students are now signed up on Khan
Academy dwarfing all the largest test
prep organizations by 4 or 5 times why
don't your organization react to the
college cheating scandal did he change
how you all do business yeah we
cooperated with federal authorities in
the scandal and closed the loophole that
was used so the safest place the most
secure place take the SAT turns out to
be at your own school or maybe on a
Saturday there were small environments
we designed for students who need
accommodations who have special needs
and that was exploited here so we'll be
much more careful in those situations
that identity has proven several times
over so we can solve a security problem
of Yale but I think the deeper anxiety
in the varsity blues case is a let's
crack down on cheating and I'm all for
it we will keep working with authorities
and you'll hear more
that how is it determined they said you
said don't call it adversity score the
resourcefulness score how is that going
to work what are you going to do later
today you're going to well yeah I want I
just want to be very clear with the
public we are going to publish by 12:00
p.m. today exactly how this is
calculated and remember it's not an
individual score for that student it
really is about the broad context they
grew up in so every kid in the same
neighborhood gets the same score for
their neighborhood and every kid in the
same school gets the same golf score for
their school and what they don't know
the score and that could be made
available we're talking about that but
but the thing is it's no insight to
families that they don't have many
resources this is not a revelation let's
be honest here what's exciting what gets
interesting is those students who
despite those situations nonetheless
achieved so much and those are within
every racial community in this country
race is not a factor race is not a
factor and so in the Asian community as
all of us should know they're their core
Asians who and from diverse environments
who face enormous challenge it'll show
them it'll show within the white
community the rural white community will
emerge here and be seen in a different
way we're gonna see that in the
african-american community Latino
community what I will say Gail is as
much as certain races disproportionally
live in neighborhoods with more crime
with the more difficult housing
situations you're gonna see more of
their efforts show up here well it's
controversial it's not and you seem to
have an answer for all the controversy
David Coleman thank you very much sir
for joining us today
thank you